for decades after the collapse of the
Soviet Union,
Ukraine went the way of direct overt
interference of Western countries in its
internal affairs, and in Russia
they tried to do the same, but
unfortunately in Ukraine they managed to instill in the
minds of millions of people
such pseudo-values ​​that led to the
fact that in this territory
actually created anti-
Russians, Russia’s clash with this neo-Nazi regime that emerged on the territory of
Ukraine
would have been inevitable if
in February the appropriate appropriate action had not been taken
on our part,
everything would have been the same only from the worst
positions for us, then foreign
powers warmed their hands on the tragedy of our
people  they didn’t care about both the Whites and the
Reds, they pursued their interests,
weakened and tore historical Russia to
pieces, and today, continuously supplying
weapons to Ukraine,
transferring mercenaries there, they are
Absolutely ruthless towards its citizens, at
their expense, they are promoting their geopolitical
goals that  they have nothing to do with the
interests of the Ukrainian people, they are
also aimed at weakening the collapse and
destruction of Russia, these efforts are
ongoing and they
underlie the events that are
taking place in Ukraine
We will never allow this to be done,
we will defend our Fatherland as well as
our heroic ancestors
need after all  the grain was peeled off to separate
and show
where the
real facts are And where something was invented,
but if our exhibition today is
dedicated to events in Ukraine, then Well, of
course, how can you even
say that the Ukrainian front
liberated Europe, that it was Ukraine that
liberated Europe, but some
you understand nonsense And that
there were only Ukrainians
and the Karelian front there that only Karelians fought
and the
Leningrad front there only Leningraders
fought
and Voronezh Voronezh about the Steppe
Mongol-Tatars
and the steppe dwellers are some kind of nonsense But this nonsense is
repeated in Europe at first glance
such  very respectable people and are
pumping this nonsense into the heads of millions of
people
To a large extent, the level of
well-being that has been achieved in the
former colonial powers is based
on the robbery of Africa, this is well known to everyone.
Actually, researchers in the
same Europe do not
hide this, and there they say, on the grief
and suffering of
African peoples, it was built to a
large extent
completely no, but  to a large extent, the
well-being of the colonial powers is an
obvious fact of the robbery of the
slave trade, of course, let's look at India, a
very talented
people, purposeful
with such a sound internal development,
they will certainly achieve outstanding
results
India will achieve outstanding results in
its development, there are no doubts
and almost one and a half billion people, this is
potential